and thank you guys so much this was such
a great informative panel Dillon Lorenz
Elizabeth and Soledad that was awesome
thank you thank thank you so much to our
whole panel and Kelly and look forward
to seeing you here for additional
programs during the history film forum
and Lawrence's film Black Panthers the
Vanguard of the revolution will be
playing here on Sunday so thank you very
much for coming
[Applause]
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3 to
join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
each week American artifacts takes you
to museums and historic places to learn
what artifacts reveal about American
history Williamsburg was the capital
city of Virginia from 1705 to 1779 up
next we take a tour of the courthouse
building with site supervisor Tom hey we
learn about the legal process in the
colonial era and the role of justices
clerks and lawyers both before and after
the American Revolution my name's Tom
hey I'm site supervisor of the
courthouse Capitol in jail here at
Colonial Williamsburg and we are
currently in the courthouse of 1770 this
courthouse served as the courthouse for
both the city of Williamsburg that is
the hustings court as well as the James
City County Court each court met here
once a month for about three or four
days the courts were the local
government of the 18th century so they
not only have judicial business people
coming here to sue or be sued but they
also come here to get tavern licenses to
be appointed to various minor offices
and not take care of widows and orphans
any number of things like that being
part of the British Empire they were
following the English common law as
adapted by a Virginia statute law and of
course the Virginia General Assembly as
we'll see in a while
had been meeting since 1619 so that
means by the time of the revolution that
Virginia's had his own homegrown law for
over a hundred and fifty years to
enforce the judges who set up here on
the high bench behind me they were the
leaders of local society so for a county
court they were appointed by the royal
governor based on nominations from the
already sitting justices for the city
court they are the mayor and aldermen of
the city and that was a soft
perpetuating body they serve for life or
goodbye
havior which meant that most of them
served for life but every once in a
while one would act so egregious as to
really annoy the governor and be kicked
off his County bench that was rare but
fairly interesting when it happens
everyone who filled a position here was
appointed as a matter of fact that's
true for all of Virginia government with
the exception of membership in the House
of Burgesses and that's the only
position filled by a by-election can you
give us an example of a trial that might
have taken place here well sure there
were a number of different ones up one
of the ones that took place here was a
woman Mary Whaley who was growing
tobacco and she was a widow by then and
she had hired a man to move her tobacco
to market and well he was a little bit
sloppy or had an accident in the way
over there and her entire years of
tobacco production was dumped into the
river so she sued to collect the the
value of her years worth of work the
court acted pretty reasonably it appears
they sent a jury of tobacco planters as
a jury of inquiry to examine the damaged
tobacco and they ended up with a damage
estimate that was not everything that
Mary Whaley asked for it was between a
third and a half of what they asked for
so it appeared the jury decided that the
truth lay somewhere between the two
extremes jury trials did happen on an
almost monthly basis and they were
usually juries were usually impaneled
for civil suits on since criminal cases
here for the most part were misdemeanors
it's a that meant that by Virginia
tradition you rarely have a criminal
jury trial for misdemeanors usually they
only occurred for felony trials of free
people and that be down at the Capitol
for the most part for misdemeanors
people were fined it say for very minor
crimes like
failure to attend church being drunk in
public or cursing in public it's a for
theft you might be whipped
it's a and for fairly rare crimes this
is perjury forgery are cheating and
gaming you might spend two hours in the
pillories your ears nailed to the boards
of the pillory and after two hours you'd
be released by having your ears cut off
but as I say that that's rare any free
subject of His Majesty whiter black male
or female could come in here - what -
watch trial but as a tradition and it's
not written in law anywhere it's but as
a tradition the enslaved portion of the
population was only allowed inside this
building when the court wanted them here
to be a witness or a defendant perhaps
we can see where the justices sat they
are figuratively and literally above
everyone else in society with the chief
magistrate they're in the chair in the
center and you might notice he's
directly underneath his Majesty's coat
of arms as a matter of fact in the 18th
century they said that subordinate
magistrates are tributaries of the
mainstream of His Majesty's Authority so
they even though they have gubernatorial
appointments the king has a royal
appointment so they do meet under the
Kings authority so that's where they
said jury sat on the lower bench beneath
them and a jury would not just like a
jury today make decisions as to the
points of fact in a case the judges make
decisions as to points of law and when
the jury has to render their verdict why
sometimes they would do it without
leaving the bench other times they would
be sequestered in a jury room and they
would stay in there without benefit of
meat drink candle or fire and that means
that one of our side rooms is a jury
room the clerk of the court sitting here
at the table in the centre well he was
the legal authority here you are
appointed as a judge based entirely on
your social level the position of your
family in society but no to be a clerk
of the court you have to
you work for the secretary of the colony
anywhere from three to five years and he
will appoint you as clerk of the County
Court and every time the clerk touches
pen to paper he's paid and that means
the justices can refer and defer to his
professional level of knowledge of the
law where I am right here is where the
attorney sat and the use of attorneys is
growing in the 18th century so local
attorneys would sit here in the General
Court there'd be attorneys like Patrick
Henry or Thomas Jefferson I'd say but
increasingly we can see a growth of
attorneys as a legal profession at this
time and then finally the enforcement
officers of the court who sat in the
boxes to either side to sheriff in
deputy sheriff they would serve written
warrant summonses and subpoenas they
would ensure that the orders of the
court were carried out an order was kept
in the court and they're paid by fees
for everything they do as a matter of
fact the clerk and the sheriff all have
their fee set by law and that's a fee
schedule on the side wall right there
how much did the function of the court
change from being a colony during the
revolution and after that's a
fascinating question I would tell you
that most historians will say it changed
very little I mean we know they took
down the Kings coat of arms they stopped
saying god saved the king and started
saying god save the commonwealth of
virginia and they continued to use the
same paperwork that started off with the
phrase by the grace of God and King
George the third King of Great Britain
France and Ireland and they would just
draw a line through that part of the pre
printed form because it'd be too
expensive to throw them away so very few
changes the very first thing that would
happen in a court session is the very
first day you're just gonna have the
clerk of the court usually in one of the
front side rooms and it would be his
duty to put the docket together so
people who are anxious to sue or
perhaps not so anxious to be sued or
people who are here to be reappointed as
a tobacco inspector or post bond as a as
a tavern keeper they would all come and
see the clerk and find out where in that
three or four day docket they could
reasonably expect their case to come up
with and that's the first day that takes
about a day to put that docket together
then the first day of the court session
itself well nothing happens until you
get a minimum of our quorum of
magistrates up here I'd say and that's
dependent on what's going to happen it's
going to be three four perhaps a sanity
hearing for four civil suits or five for
a felony criminal trial of an enslaved
person so you have to wait till you have
the proper number of justices and they
sit up here and the clerk would sit here
at the table as I said and he's
critically important we know from
Richmond County court up in the northern
part of Virginia there was one time
where the clerk unfortunately was ill
and they had to cancel court that's how
important the clerk is I don't say so
Court would begin to meet about midday
it say if there were any criminal
procedures they always handle those
first otherwise you very quickly get
into people suing one another most suits
for debts are not very exciting as a
matter of fact almost all business
transactions in the colony of Virginia
occurred by credit and it was credit
kept on a person's books and that's
called book debt and if you want to sue
someone and be insure that you are going
to collect that you can sue based on
book debt but you can also get the court
to bond the debt which makes it a debt
of higher dignity and if a person dies
the executor of the state must pay off
all bond debt before getting to the book
debt so lots of suits for debt not very
exciting but that's where they occurred
here there might be a Oh twice a year
after the local grand jury meets you're
gonna see people presented for a failure
to attend church for road inspectors not
keeping up their section of the road
dude for people not reporting their tie
the Bulls are not teaching their
children the basic catechism of the
church a number of things like that so
there were a few morals charges there
might be women brought up here for the
burying of a bass born or bastard
children as well it's a but in the main
civil and administrative matters come
first they knew what the laws were by
virtue of growing up in the society I
mean the law is only partly the written
law or the luck scripta it's also the
Lexx non-scripted our unwritten law that
is the law of tradition in the finest of
southern or new england terms it's what
we do it this way because we always have
done it this way or this is the way that
granddad did it I'd say so
you grow up with these these certainties
these verities of life that's a you know
and it's things that people are taught
as very young children if it's not yours
don't take it it's a so people be
brought in here for things like that but
there there were very few surprises in
court
people knew when they had done wrong and
when you're arrested you are informed as
to why you're arrested in a criminal
case if you're served with the summons
to come to court for a civil case well
usually if we're in debt we know were in
debt at the time and so you know who's
bringing you to court what is
interesting is unlike today there is one
alternative in a debt suit that well
hasn't been around since the 1870s and
that is if you're found that you do in
fact own a debt there's a judgment debt
against you
it's a then that means that you could
end up serving 20 days in the local
debtors prison and this Court has the
authority to send you there you're
released on the 21st day still owning
every penny of the debt I'd say but
you've gone through the humiliation of
having to serve time in debtors prison
and after that well in order to get out
of debtors prison you have to turn over
to the court of schedule of all your
worldly possessions that can be sold
satisfied the debt so that's a change in
between Virginia law in English law in
in England you stay in debtors prison
until the debts paid most people see a
little bit of a problem with that idea
it's a so in Virginia they limited to 20
days a number of the men who sat upon
the original bench in this building had
attended the College of William and Mary
on the other hand there was George with
the first law professor of this country
who was a city justice and one-time
mayor of actually twice mayor of the
city and he was taught entirely at home
as a matter of fact we are told that his
mother taught him both Greek and Latin
and he was so well versed in in
languages that later in life he taught
himself Hebrew so he could read the Old
Testament in the original quite a
fascinating man who's ever been sitting
on the bench it will serve as the most
active magistrate that is the chief
magistrate and that makes sense he's
most experienced and he is the one who
knows the local population the best but
the other said to either side of him and
every decision is a group decision
so single magistrate can't make a single
decision in a court all by himself but
I'm sure that there was a great degree
of agreement amongst the amongst the
justices since they call come from the
highest level of local society I'm sure
they all shared the same worldview still
allowing for plenty of personality
disagreements between them but I'm sure
they all saw the world the same way and
would they have all lived in
Williamsburg or the surrounding area
they all would have lived in
Williamsburg or in James City County so
if we were outside this courthouse we
could see the home of of Payton Randolph
newest member of the city court george
whiffs house also a member of the city
court
it's a we could see the home of john
randolph who was member the city in
county court and robb
Carter Nicholas a member of the City and
County Court plus any number we do know
the average judge in James City County
owned on average about eight hundred
acres but there were a number of them
that know two or three thousand acres so
they were extremely well-to-do gentlemen
they were not paid for being judges no
no they they served for the honor of the
position and two degree that makes sense
the better off you are in society the
more free time you have available to you
in that society and so if advantages in
society or proportional to your position
in society shows that your public
service to that society be at least that
was their territory
Lessig a latarian dinars but it does
have a logic to it
and what about the education for the
lawyers do they have to pass a test to
be one yes as a matter of fact now most
lawyers learn to become a lawyer by
reading the law either by themselves as
Patrick Henry did or underneath an other
attorney such as George Wythe or Thomas
Jefferson who read law under George
Wythe and then when you think that you
have sufficient knowledge of the law you
would go and be interviewed by two or
three attorneys of the High Court
interestingly most of those who did the
interviews lived right here in town so
when you look at lawyer licenses from
the 18th century we tend to see George
woofs name or Robert Carter Nicholas R
John rained off all of whom lived here
in the city and they would sign the
licenses of well the next generation of
lawyers I'd say so yes you had to prove
a basic knowledge of the law but we know
of one Richmond County justice a landing
Carter who well was the type of
personality who complained about most
things in life and he went on to say
that you could make a perfectly good
knowledge or a perfectly good living as
an attorney by the knowledge of five or
six writs so he didn't think much of
attorneys at all
of course he lost arguments do them all
the time the one thing to keep in mind
is that at least for the free part of
the population this was a system that
most people supported and to give you an
idea of what I mean by that this system
was developed by the 1630s when the
first county courthouses were
established in Virginia and they made no
significant change in the system until
the 1820s so this system or this
institution stayed relatively untouched
by the change of centuries and the
change in government during revolution
so obviously it enjoyed a great deal of
support from the local population people
felt that it was fair that's a and of
course that is the the free part of the
population I suspect that the enslaved
part of the population may have had a
different viewpoint on the whole system
this represents the last quarter of the
18th century so it starts off with the
last few years of Virginia being part of
the British Empire that's a and it
represents the beginning of the the new
Republican form of government both the
republic of virginia as many people
thought of it and then shortly
thereafter the the new united states of
america there were as i mentioned two
courts that met here so each court had
its own clerk's office for the the
storage of records this was a court of
record so having those records kept in
good form and searchable was very
important so as a court of record they
had to have those kept it say and then
one room as the match is true not too
surprisingly that's the fancies of the
side rooms and then the jury room a very
plain room
but that's where the juried be
sequestered again with no nothing to eat
or drink no light or heat until they
render their verdict the first court
that meets here the first Monday of the
month for three or four days is the
Williamsburg customs court that is the
Municipal Court since it was the
Municipal Court of the capital city you
could sue anyone in this court who lived
in Virginia and the writ of this court
ran the entire length and breadth of
Virginia in other words it was a very
convenient court for British creditors
to come or rather their lawyers and sue
people who owed them money now the
second week of the month the James City
County court was in session here and
they are an extremely typical court of
the time period I'd say so they did what
the other 59 or 60 County courts of
Virginia did which is actually a major
advantage for us in our study of this
institution because the records above
the city and county court were at the
beginning of the American Civil War sent
up to Richmond and they were still in
Richmond at the end of the Civil War
when a third of Richmond was burnt down
to the ground so sadly we have lost
those records so our knowledge of this
institution is based almost entirely but
on studying other courts other county
courts are the one other city or
Municipal Court that is the Hessians
Court of Norfolk this is a typical three
or four strand whip that we'd use of the
time period immediately outside we do
have the whipping post next to the
stocks and pillories and a person could
be whit by the court but no more than 39
times I'd say which is one of the few
crossovers between biblical law and
English common law that's a so if a
person got taken outside it's a they
would be chained or manacle to the
whipping post and the deputy sheriff our
constable would whip them 1020
or 29 times upon order of the court and
they did get a fee for that and the fee
is is listed there on the fee schedule
now I did mention that people could be
brought here enslaved people brought
here and tried for felonies the basic
felony punishment was death by hanging
however for certain felonies you could
receive the benefit of clergy which is a
holdover from pre-reformation england
and at that time the only people who
could be who could receive the benefit
of clergy would be members of the clergy
now eventually with the reformation and
expanded beyond that by our time period
by the time this building was built what
it meant is if you were found guilty of
a felony crime then the chief magistrate
would tell you that you have been found
guilty and asks you if he had anything
to say and at that point the defendant
would say I plead the benefit of clergy
or I demand my clergy and what that
means is that you were whole he or she
would hold out their left hand that's a
and a branding-iron be brought out of
going a nice cheery read and it would be
applied to the broad of the left hand
like this and the person was expected by
tradition to yell out god save the king
and they carry the brain for the rest of
their life
this shows a t4 thief the other brand
was M for manslaughter and again at this
level this would be done to enslaved
people at the High Court it was done to
free people but this would continue in
American jurisprudence in most the
colonies until the beginning of the 19th
century then it gradually faded out and
needless to say only be branded for a
few moments the ultimate lesson we would
like people to take away from this
building is that human nature hasn't
changed
perhaps some means of expressing that
has but the people of the 18th century
were as fully human
fully real and fully argumentative as we
are today that's what we hope you can
watch this and other American artifacts
programs by visiting our website at
c-span org slash history
but Booker T said to them you know the
we have college-age kids covered here in
Alabama but it's really the the kids in
the elementary schools that are
suffering they're just not the
african-american kids are getting poor
education horrible buildings
you're just not anything you know
separate and not equal Sunday night on
cue a documentary filmmaker Aviva
kempner talks about her latest film
Rosenwald about Julius Rosenwald and his
partnership with Booker T Washington and
the african-american communities in the
south to build schools and bring
elementary education to children in
rural America so first Julius Rosenwald
said oh you know Sears puts together
these kit houses why don't we just use
the kid houses and the best thing Booker
T Washington ever did was saying no I
want just like we do at Tuskegee I want
the communities to build it so first
these six goals were built and that's
really amazing but from that it morphed
into 5,000 schools all over the South
including Maryland Sunday night at 8:00
Eastern on c-span's Q&A
all weekend American History TV is
featuring Hartford Connecticut Samuel
Clemens more commonly known as Mark
Twain lived in Hartford while writing
The Adventures of Tom Sawyer and The
Adventures of Huckleberry Finn c-span
cities tour staff recently visited many
sites showcasing the city's history
learn more about Hartford all weekend
here on American history TV
Connecticut 50 objects 50 stories is an
exhibit that came together in 2015 when
we went all over the state and asked
people to send us images of objects that
represent stories that they feel to find
Connecticut as a place as a people and
as an idea from those submissions we
then chose 50 that aren't the defining
stories of Connecticut but really helped
us to understand the complexity and the
depth of our history here the artifacts
that are on display here related to the
American Revolution really show how
Connecticut has played a role in in most
of American history we didn't have a lot
of battles in Connecticut there were
some along the coastlines there was a
raid on Danbury but by and large we
supplied the Continental Army
we provided leadership we provided
support and Connecticut as a state
continues that role over the following
centuries a number of the items that we
have here at the Connecticut Historical
Society that are about the American
Revolution are here in our exhibit
Connecticut 50 objects of 50 stories the
first is Nathan Hales diary this is an
incredible piece Nathan Hale is
Connecticut State hero he was born in
Coventry and he was a farmer and a
schoolteacher but he joined the
Continental Army and he served with
Washington's troops outside of Boston he
volunteers on a spying mission and goes
down to New York at that time he was
caught and then he was hanged and he's
most known for his quote my only regret
is that I have only one life to give for
my country the Diary is really
incredible because it talks a lot about
everyday life and what it was like to be
in the Continental Army how people were
relating to each other what they were
thinking about what their concerns and
worries were what they did on a day to
day basis it really gives us a look at
what it was like to be a soldier in the
Continental Army the other piece we have
here is Monson Heights jacket he was one
of one of the kinetic UNS who decided to
stay loyal to the crown
about 20% of the population of
Connecticut were loyalists Hoyt served
in the revolution he served the British
crown and he fought against the
Revolutionary Army after his time served
in the military he then left and he was
he moved to Canada to New Brunswick
where he became a merchant and he
actually co-owned a business with
Benedict Arnold until it burned down and
there was some disagreement in their
business relationship later he marries a
woman from Long Island and eventually
dies in about 1805 there's just some
really compelling stories here in
Connecticut about loyalists and why they
remain loyal instead of joining the
Continental Army or wanting independence
from the British government and Munson
was just one of those characters but we
have so many others in the collection if
you go into our archive and library you
can read diaries about other loyalists
and what they were thinking and why they
wanted to stay with the British
government whether that was for economic
purposes whether that was about their
identity or just even their future plans
the amount of information we have and
collections and objects related to the
American Revolution is is actually quite
large because we were founded to save
that history we have furniture from the
period we have textiles we have prints
we have books diaries letters the
Connecticut Historical Society often
runs behind the scene tours and they're
a fantastic opportunity to show members
of the public items that are in our
collection this is the waistcoat of
Colonel William Leonard he was the
commander at Fort
Griswold and grant in Connecticut my
story behind this is that on September 6
1781 there was an attack by British
ships someone at the fort noticed the
enemy flag and reported it and so the
idea was to fire off two shots which
marked enemies approaching the infamous
Benedict Arnold was on one of the
approaching British ships and he knew
that this is what they're supposed to do
so he fired a third shot which typically
meant that friendlies were approaching
this accounts for why there was slow
reinforcements to come to the fort
so the British attacked the fort they
eventually went out and the story goes
that Colonel ed yard offered over his
sword to a British general to surrender
and then that general actually stabbed
leaded which accounts for the holes in
the waistcoat killing him along with the
punctured marks there were originally
blood stains from William Leonard on the
waistcoat however when it was given to
the CHS in 1841 it was decided that the
blood stains were too gruesome for the
ladies so they were actually washed out
of the waistcoat which if you ask any
historian or archivists or collections
person now they would probably grimace
at the thought so the second article
that we've taken out is the cloak of
Deborah champion she was 22 years old
from New London Connecticut and her
father Henry was the commissary general
for the Patriots and he was trying to
send messages to George Washington who
was stationed at Boston at the time and
originally he wanted to send his son
Henry but thought that he would get
stopped more easily so he sent his
daughter Deborah and she was actually
wearing this cloak when she was sneaking
messages past the British and she would
wear this cloak and she would hide the
messages within her bodice and she also
wore it's called the Kailash it's a bit
like a large bonnet and she didn't want
to wear it at first but her mother
insisted that she did and later she
remarked that it was a good thing she
did because she was able to pull it over
her head as she was stopped by loyalist
officers and they just remark that she
was an old lady and that she could pass
through and she later wrote a letter to
her friend patience telling about her
tales while she was writing it her
father had come in and said to make sure
she didn't give away any sort of details
as to where George Washington was
stationed or anything she had heard on
his whereabouts and
numbers so our final object that we're
showing today is a flag from the second
Connecticut regiment it is the last
Connecticut infantry color flag left in
existence that we know of many people
question its authenticity as because of
its color most flags for the Connecticut
2nd regiment were blue at that time and
this is obviously a deep red and they
actually think it was an earlier
Connecticut militia flag and that they
had just continued to use it during the
American Revolution the flag is assumed
to be made out of silk with metallic dye
which is a part of the reason that it's
so withered not only because of time but
because the metallic dye would have
eaten away at the silk it's preserved in
two pieces of mesh and then suspended
one of the reasons that the Connecticut
Historical Society has so many of these
Revolutionary War era artifacts is
because we were founded in 1825 we were
founded just the year before the 50th
anniversary of the American Revolution
and we were founded because the men and
women of Connecticut felt like we were
losing our history from that period that
it was disappearing that it was being
scattered amongst people's homes and
their own personal collections and so
they wanted to create institutions like
the CHS where you can bring those
materials together so they could be
preserved they could be shared and that
we could learn from them for future
generations
so now 190 years later we're able to
pull out items like this red coat like
Nathan's Hales diary like a flag from
the revolution since so many other
materials that that continue to tell us
new stories that we hadn't known in the
past about periods that really helped us
become who we are today
our cities tour staff recently traveled
to Hartford Connecticut to learn about
its rich history learn more about
Hartford and the other stops on our tour
at c-span org slash cities tour you're
watching American history TV all weekend
every weekend on c-span three coming up
next on American history TV author and
Arizona State University professor
Matthew Garcia talks about labor history
in California starting in the early 20th
century professor Garcia talks about the
different agricultural labor movements
in the region and explores some of the
major working-class leaders including
Cesar Chavez we interviewed mr. Garcia
at the Western history Association's
annual conference in Portland Oregon in
October this is about 20 minutes
Matt Garcia what inspired you to write
and study labor and working-class
history in California well I come from a
working-class family I was born into a
Mexican and Anglo family of both sides
and was interesting is that my Mexican
side picked fruit they were farm workers
and food chain workers and on my Anglo
side my grandfather particularly worked
for sanchez so they were white-collar
workers and food and so I was interested
in how those two things come to bear in
the production and fruit and farmworkers
and labor
when did Labour's first begin to
organize in California well there was a
lot of organizing a 19th century I'm
primarily a 20th century historian so
what I always look at is that period in
the early 20th century especially with
farm workers with the Wheatland hop
riots and that was 1913 and they were
organizing to get their rights you know
to be part of the to have dignity and
their jobs and that came up through the
1930s with the cotton strike in 1933 and
then there was a hope that there would
be collective bargaining rights in 1935
and those hopes were dashed by the
National Labor Relations Act
yeah let's come back to the National
Labor Relations Act and can you try to
set the stage for us you're talking
mostly about agricultural workers in
California at this point and what was
being grown and what were the conditions
for for workers at that time well
virtually everything was being ghrelin
in California as I said I'm from a
citrus family so I was interested in
citrus but everything from barley and
hops for beer and other things to fruits
and melons and that kind of thing so the
question the question was what were the
conditions like for these agricultural
workers
so what growers were trying to do is
keep workers mobile in certain areas of
California which would inhibit their
ability to organize unions be in one
place at like industrial unions so
that's one of the features of farm work
that's unique and keeps them moving and
organize that wasn't true though in
citrus where citrus was grown virtually
a year round because of the diversity in
citrus so that's why I focus on citrus
and the attempt to form unions there but
they were also using different tactics
to prevent unions in citrus as well
so describe what it would be like for a
citrus grow the laborers yeah well what
was it like to work on a citrus pond
oh it was hard labor they had to carry
their Clippers their ladders the baskets
they put the fruit into sometimes they
brought their children that were
referred to as rathas or rats that would
run around and scurry around the bottom
of the tree for all fruit that fell and
that was always a way of adding to the
yield that of course helped increase the
amount of money that the worker would
make but for the most part they didn't
have unions to take care of themselves
some citrus workers worked in
unincorporated places such as my family
and then there were company towns as
well that they moved into and were
monitored constantly by growers so the
this is the early 1900's that that
you're focusing on what was what was
happening that led to the organization
of these workers and was it unique to
California or was a labor movement
happening nationwide at that time in our
history well as you got into the 1930s
you had the Great Depression and there
was foment for unions throughout the
country this is even happening earlier
in the progressive movement but in
particular with regards to agriculture
in the West because California is such
an agricultural state and one of the
arguments I make about Los Angeles it's
primarily an agricultural town beaten
before World War two that agriculture
was the place that
founded in terms of whether unions were
going to take off so in 1933 in
particular in the San Joaquin Valley
there was a cotton strike mostly amongst
Mexican workers and there was a lot of
hope that was shared across the country
about how the government might give them
collective bargaining rights and the
National Labor Relations Act it came it
gave collective bargaining rights to
industrial workers but unfortunately
farm workers were left out and their
hopes were dashed almost for well
actually for more than two decades
why were they left out I think there's
some biases against farm workers it's a
mobile workforce right it's an immigrant
workforce and in some cases with Mexican
it is an foreign workforce so they're
assumed to not be invested and to be
transient and therefore unorganized able
and through the twentieth century then
the effort was made by certain
individuals first in esto de Larsa and
then later on Cesar Chavez to prove them
wrong
so those are two names of leaders but
most people have probably heard of Cesar
Chavez the first man you mentioned can
you talk a little bit more about him and
what his role was so Nestle Galarza
wrote strangers in the field he was a
kind of labour intellectual he was
someone that very early on recognized
something very problematic in the labor
system that came after the National
Labor Relations Act in during World War
two which was the bracero program so the
bracero program was this guest worker
program that brought Mexican
to the United States almost entirely men
4.6 million contracts over that time
between 1942 and 1964 and Ernesto
Galarza tried to or did organize and
tried to eliminate or end that bracero
program he did not succeed but he tried
mightily and it was Cesar Chavez that
and and the National Farm Workers
Association that picked up that work and
moved it forward and actually realized
that goal in 1960s can you talk a little
bit more about the bracero program and
why that was a federal program yes was
an executive order that then was
supported by the Congress very heavily
influenced by the lobby of agricultural
owners or agribusiness and the idea was
you know you bring in these Mexican
workers it was argued that they were
people that would come in and help be
the kind of domestic support system
during World War two right because all
the workers went to the frontlines in
Europe or in Japan well that turned out
to be really not the reason for the
bracero program the reason was that
there they wanted attractable and
migratory workforce that they could
ensure would not organize against them
and so that continued well after World
War two
there was an attempt to argue that the
Korean War was an important precedent or
important motivation for extending it
over that time people like your Nestor
Galarza said this is a false argument
that the real reason is that you just
want this tractable foreign labor that
we can expel at any time because it was
not citizen labor so what methods did
these labor organizers use to try to
facilitate change well in or less Ogel
arses case he published widely strangers
in the field is one organized unions in
some cases testified in Congress right
so incredibly active there was even at
times an attempt to organize braceros
but he ultimately decided that braceros
were not organized ax bellowing to be
people given their status that could
help bring collective bargaining to farm
workers even though braceros did strike
and even though braceros were at times
very militant on their own behalf but
unethical arson made that decision that
that wouldn't happen
so
jumping ahead to Cesar Chavez and the
Farm Workers movement what can you tell
us about about that movement and how
different was it from the earlier
protests that you mentioned in the 30s
for instance right so there's Edward r
murrow who helped popularize the
struggle against the bracero program it
was a CBS show called harvest of shame
that really brought attention to the
bracero program and its effect across
the country on agriculture I think Cesar
Chavez learned a lot from that that
public relations mattered and that
trying to export the story of
exploitation in the fields to urban and
areas was really important right because
the farm the farm is a mobile work site
it's changing with seasons that's
changing with the harvest so one of the
innovations that Cesar Chavez the United
Farm Workers used was the boycott and
that took that struggle out of the
fields and into where most people are
living and where they're consuming the
fruits of these people's labor which is
the cities and that was really the
linchpin the key to their success and so
by 1970 they were able to put enough
pressure on growers to through this
tactic to achieve the first contracts in
California farm labor history
you've talked about the laborers in this
working class and some of the leaders
what about the the corporation's work
were they usually large growers or are
you talk were the laborers protesting
conditions across the board and where
there are all kinds of different
companies that owned these farms they
were very diverse right so there were
corporate owners there are people that
lived in the east and owned large tracts
of land in the West those corporate
owners were frequently very influenced
by boycotts they didn't want the stigma
of being an exploiter of workers they
were trying to sell products to all of
their consumers in the east and so they
didn't want that they often settled out
with the United Farm Workers earlier
than the local growers who were bigger
than you know the smaller growers but
they were they were very stubborn they
were invested in their own power in in
developing in particular grapes and
selling those grapes and it was a kind
of culture of the farm of the farmer or
really a grower but they came as farmers
and then became growers really and so
they often maligned their corporate
peers for settling and they dug in their
heels and really that was the key in
terms of the farm workers struggle how
do you break that local grower culture
that's very vested in
keeping things the way they are in
California and that was the that was the
struggle we mentioned the National Labor
Relations Act
what other legislation was passed
following that that enabled agricultural
workers to organize what was mostly
discouraging I think the end of the
bracero program was really a very
important moments not a piece of
legislation it's kind of a passage of
the legislation I would say the next big
legislation was after 1970 when
collective bargaining rights came to
grow excuse me to farm workers in the
agricultural labor relations act of
California so it mirrored the National
Labor Relations Act
it gave collective bargaining rights to
farm workers but in the state of
California and that was 1975 when Jerry
Brown was first time he was governor and
he actually said that that was the
signal achievement of his first time as
governor to pass this law and it was
regarded as the best early labor law in
the country
the United Farm Workers and and farm
farm workers in general benefited
greatly from it but for reasons that I
go into in my book it didn't it wasn't
an act or a law that the UFW followed
upon they they kind of abandoned it in
the nineteen the end of the 1970s around
77 78 they started to pull back from the
law
so looking at this whole period of time
from about the 30s through the 70s how
did the conditions for the farmworkers
change over that period right so
incredibly important changes were
achieved by the farmworkers movement in
terms of places to go to the restroom
and the fields right so restrooms were
provided water was provided brakes were
provided health a healthcare system that
the United Farm Workers ran was formed
there were all these things that had not
existed before the 1960s that the
success of the United farmworkers made
possible so those were really epic
changes in farm labor unfortunately
because of the failure to follow up on
the agricultural labor relations act and
make good on those boycott the boy the
achievement of the boycott and the
contracts of 1970 those things haven't
lasted and immigration has been a big
influence in terms of the struggle to
continue to organize farmworkers
early on you talked about the workforce
being mainly Mexico yes but not
exclusively right Filipinos were
actually the ones that started the grape
strike in 1965 and then it was Mexicans
that joined with them and that's what's
special about the United farmworkers
there's a multi-ethnic movement so i
sorry for interrupting you know that's
one of the big struggles right now on
farm worker history is to get away from
the idea that it was all about mexicans
and it was all about Cesar Chavez
actually the Filipinos were the ones
that started the the the success that
became the United farmworkers in 1965
right and and now what do you think is
the state of farmworkers in California
and can you talk about the ethnic and
racial makeup of the workforce in
general now is it very different from
what it was two decades ago four decades
ago it was more diverse from the 30s
until the 1970s as I mentioned the
Filipinos started the grape strike in 65
this is the 50th anniversary this year
of that there were Yemeni workers who
are now being written about by farm
worker historians there were a lot of
african-american farm workers that like
Dorothea Lange documented but I would
say because of immigration after 1970
that that workforce became predominantly
Latino and more
and most specifically Mexican and then
in more and more indigenous so
indigenous Mexican right so the growth
of that population has made that
population much more monochromatic if
you will right more similar than
different and I think that the kind of
diversity we saw in the 60s and 70s is
not there today you've published several
books you have a current book project
can you just tell us a little bit about
that so my first book was really
interested in the bottom-up the
farmworkers the next project was
interested in the organizers the people
that built the farmworkers movement what
I believe in terms of labor history is
that we also have to do top-down history
we can't neglect the people that are the
owners and to understand the whole
system you have to study them so I found
a very compelling figure and Eli Black
Eli Black was the CEO of United brands
that included United Fruit but also
inner harvest that made deals with Cesar
Chavez to have the farmworkers on his
farms in Imperial Valley and Salinas
Valley be represented by the uff
is highly controversial some of those
growers in the San Joaquin Valley who
did not want to settle out with ufw
maligned eli black in anti-semitic terms
because he was jewish but in 1975 he
committed suicide by jumping off the
44th floor of the pan-american milk
building in midtown Manhattan why
because he was bribing the president of
Honduras to lower tariffs with the
banana plantations he owned in Central
America so while he was doing this
incredible work with cesar chavez and
bringing unions to his workers in the
lettuce fields of California he was
undermining the ability of people
working for him in the banana
plantations in Central America to have
health care to have a livable wage all
of those things that you know we see as
kind of the Progressive Era edge of farm
labor organizing it's a very complex man
I hope to get even more even deeper into
that complexity as I project
do you have an expected date for
publishing the book probably we're
looking at about 2017 yeah well thank
you very much for joining us I
appreciate it Thank You Susan
Monday is Martin Luther King jr. Day and
with Congress not in session we have
featured programs and all three c-span
networks on c-span at 11:30 a.m. Eastern
live coverage of the British House of
Commons debate on whether to ban Donald
Trump from their country that debates
expected to last three hours our
coverage will re-air at 8:00 Eastern on
c-span 2's book TV at 6:30 p.m. Eastern
University of Wisconsin professor
William P Jones and his book the march
on Washington jobs freedom and the
forgotten history of civil rights when a
Phillip Randolph went to reorganize this
March that he had called off back in
1941 everybody said well you better get
mine Luther King you need to get his
support and he went to Martin Luther
King and Martin Luther King said well
let I will support you but let's expand
the goals of the March the March is not
just about winning equal access to jobs
fighting employment discrimination it's
also about winning the right to vote in
the south and at eight-thirty Georgia
representative John Lewis recalls his
involvement in the civil rights movement
in his book March book 2 the second part
of an illustrated adaptation of his life
and on American history TV on c-span 3
at 2:00 p.m. Eastern roham Al Von D
international history professor at the
London School of Economics and political
science on a rands Cold War partnership
of the United States Iran had to look to
a third power to preserve its
independence and its sovereignty against
the imperial ambitions of Britain and
Russia in the 1930s Iran had looked to
Germany to play that role and after the
Second World War a whole generation of
Iranian statesmen including the Shah
looked to the United States as a country
that had no imperial ambitions and no
history event of colonialism in the
region and at 8 on real America a 1963
interview with the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King jr. on his nonviolent
approach to civil rights his comments on
President Kennedy's civil rights bill
and how Mahatma Ghandi influenced his
work for the complete holiday schedule
go to c-span org
you know the we have college-age kids
covered here in Alabama but it's really
the the kids in the elementary schools
that are suffering they're just not the
african-american kids are getting poor
education horrible buildings
you're just not anything you know
separate and not equal Sunday night on Q
and a documentary filmmaker Aviva
Kempner talks about her latest film
Rosenwald about Julius Rosenwald and his
partnership with Booker T Washington and
the african-american communities in the
south to build schools and bring
elementary education to children in
rural America so first Julius Rosenwald
said oh you know serious puts together
these kid houses why don't we just use
the kid houses and the best thing Booker
T Washington ever did was saying no I
want just like we do at Tuskegee I want
the communities to build it so first
these six schools were built and that's
really amazing but from that it morphed
into 5,000 schools all over the South
including Maryland Sunday night at 8:00
Eastern on c-span's Q&A
for this year's student cam documentary
contest students are telling us the
issue they want the presidential
candidates to discuss and we're hearing
about the students as they produce their
videos here's a tweet from Andrew Hanna
eighth grade social studies teacher at
Summit School in winston-salem North
Carolina at Summit eighth recording
student cam intros at the White House
Virginia congressman Bob Goodlatte
tweeted help Georgia's Sally and Jesse
with their c-span student cam project
this afternoon in row no good luck
students from Lakeside High School in
hot springs Arizona tweeted more of our
day at the Capitol
thanks again Arizona State
Representative John vines and Senator
Clark for the tour and Todd Pagal social
studies teacher at John Adams middle
school in Edison Township New Jersey
tweeted interviewing Jay Valentine 25 or
our student cam project about school
bullying there's $100,000 in prizes with
a grand prize of $5,000 the deadline is
January 20th 2016 and the winners will
be announced on March 9th for more
information visit our website student
cam dot org